now a young woman learns her fate today
five months after a deadly hit and run
thanks for staying with us at 4 30 I'm
Denise Valdez and I'm Vanessa Murphy and
for Kirsten Joyce surveillance video
captured 19 year old Joanna Messa
attempting to wipe away evidence of the
crash after hitting a pedestrian so this
happened in the early morning hours of
January 21st not too far from Lake Mead
and Mount Hood eight news now reporter
Victoria Saha was in the courtroom today
as emotions run High
I understand I made a horrible decision
that night that night haunting two
families forever Joanna Meza was driving
when she hit 20 thrilled rakia pool pool
was attempting to cross the street
not only did Mesa leave the scene she
was caught on surveillance cameras
getting out of her car to clean up the
damage of the impact then minutes later
she sped through the crash scene again
you had time to change your clothes wipe
your vehicle down believe rakia lifeless
in the street we do dogs like that not a
human being we have a whole human being
in the street and then you drove back by
her dead in the street the district
attorney also revealing there were empty
alcohol bottles at the scene meza's
attorney we're dealing with a teenager
here you know she made a bad teenage
decision the judge ultimately sentencing
Meza 5 to 15 years behind bar hours
outside the courthouse pools family
satisfied with the sentence I do
appreciate her owning up to what she did
the pool family tells me that they do
forgive Mesa and hopes that after she
gets out of prison she'll become a
changed person the judge though however
said that if Mesa had stopped and made
an anonymous phone call to 9-1-1 to get
help for a pool it could have made an
impact on her case Victoria sahab 8 News
Now